[Music]
few animals inspire more fear than
sharks
but out of the millions of people
worldwide who swim in the ocean each
year less than a hundred are attacked of
the more than 300 species of shark only
a small number are proven man-eaters the
most dangerous are Tiger shows
pool shots and great whites a bite from
them can literally cost life and live
sharks may bite people out of hunger but
often as not will bite out of simple
curiosity they'll gladly sample anything
unusual bobbing in the water like a
person just to see what it tastes like
so knowing how to respond can mean the
difference between life and death
if a shark attacks should you splash
violently go for the eyes or play dead
the correct answer is B go for the odds
splashing violently only attracts more
sharks toward you playing dead leads to
being dead a limp body tells the shark
it's time to tuck in for a big meal your
best chance is to strike at its soft
spots its eyes gills and nose make the
shark decide you're not worth the
trouble and while it's deciding get to
shore as fast as you can
and that's how you survive a shark
attack